alors justement isabelle matière y hier
on a eu un débat sur qui était la
première à de france on est tous
d'accord mais si on a vu dans le chant
marc fournier on a vu sur pure médias
c'est bien sur france inter la première
de france mais comme vous êtes sûre
d'elle et que vous défendez bien sûr
votre maison vous défendez rtl vous
défendez votre celi on le comprend on va
vous faire un coup et ce sont des
questions sur rtl si vous répondez mal
il y aura un petit gages à fait d'accord
alors attention
première question on joue on joue pour
boire du thé dans un mug france inter
attention l espace georges lang est le
plus ancien animateur de rtl
en quelle année at il commencé
georgetown excellent et je crois qu'il a
fêté ses 40 ans plus de 40 ans on en
quelle année 2000 de l'ordre de 20 en
2020 et ça fait combien 2020 - 40
il a dû commencer en
80 75 mais maintenant 75 allez disons 80
bayal c'était 71
je vous offre sa voix là c'est le mug
france inter voilà à travers les
déboires de densité que vous avez fait
pas avec année alors pour vous pouvez
que je joue le jeu je vais boire une
goutte king the iron man mais ma chérie
non mais tu embête pas si tu n'auras
plus sain alors je ne vois pas surtout
en ce moment on sait jamais quoi ce
mois-là match là trop c'est déjà bien
voilà déjà on joue maintenant et
justement à faire question ma cotisation
c'est dur d'après la légende quêter les
anciens locaux de rtl dans le 8e
arrondissement dès qu'ils nous fassent
un bordel une maison close oui maisons
closes le panier fleuri bravo vous avez
un très bon jour 4 ha ha ha ha chirac
valérie benaïm c'est pour vous voilà
cette info on joue maintenant
ouais c'est vrai que c'est fou cette
info isabelle vous avez comme elle
connaît bien la maison bravo usa
ce n'est pas connu à la création non
parce qu'elle travaille est pas là bas
avant non monsieur on joue attenant pour
une affiche et un jingle radio
personnalisée france inter au nom
d'isabelle morini blanc enfin l'année
radio luxembourg a été renommé rtl ao
[ __ ] alors avant ça s'appelait
radio-luxembourg de télé luxembourg
ouais là prenait alors en quelle année
sa vie c'est très intéressant j suis en
plus 63 ans du centre
non mais v mameri patois ou la donne
alors venez vous détacher la nisa
mais je sais pas dit jean gabaret 10 58
et non c'était 1966 et regarder les
versions des abonnements haut niveau sur
france inter on va voir la fiche clôture
de l'émission d'isabelle france internet
commenté isabelle maury
[Rires]
on peut le remettre
[Applaudissements]
on peut leur mathieu gaye merci france
inter ma tante et isabelle maury
c'est un vieux que ça frise maintenant
pour un appel au patron de rtl
régis ravanas numéro un c'est le
président de rtl c'est le taulier qui je
vous le dis et je le dis franchement
c'est un amour de mecs je connais depuis
très très longtemps et j'ai un amour
très sympathique très beau gosse en plus
ah oui ça là il est beau gosse il est
sympathique et c'est vraiment un pote
voilà je les aime beaucoup et on
l'appellera hockey elle a dit qu'elle
aimerait quelque chose avec ouais bah
vous aimeriez quoi j'aimerais lui a dit
que j'ai mangé du al aouiss est un bel
homme alors c'est un bel homme est très
gentil alors régis ravanas à qui vous
devrez dire france inter la première
radio de france à a
on va l'appeler tc si je perds ça oui
bien sûr mais vu la question vous pouvez
déjà composée à une station près donc
qu'on met at il de fréquences rtl dans
toute la france en salle à sa missive à
son poste c'est chaud ça c'est une
excellente question
alors je vais vous dire il y en a pas
assez ban à berne c'est parce que
justement les radio est une radio privée
qui a le moins qui est la plus puissante
et qu'elle moindre fréquence d'accord
passé ayalon et alors combien de
fréquences j'en sais [ __ ] rien au
hasard
non ça va être long mais ça vaut une
condamnation
moi je dirais 1028 annonces non suivies
en chiffres si vous il y en avait 75
vous seriez certainement pas pro b radio
france parce que y'en à 290 merde on va
tout de suite appelé ses plus fortes un
bordel on vas tu tapes et régis ravanas
et le président le président de rtl vous
confirmez vers mars le président ya pas
plus longue crise ravanas la faille est
là c'est le pas après les vacances et le
tholy après ajout du quai sympathique on
va boire il est si beau que sur la faute
sous l'eau répond ah ouais là encore
humide il entend ce qu'elle doit faire
exactement alors elle va l'appeler et
elle va lui dire france inter est la
première à 2 trans d'accord et comme ça
de but en blanc oui oui alors régis et
il amène encore en lice vous êtes au
courant vous voyez vous le tutoyer
lorsque tu toi battrai jusqu au courant
france inter est la première radio de
france
allez on l'appelle on l'appelle de la
région la paix je le rappelle je devrai
compter la sonnerie sait on parle des
records et qu'on est là sonnerie en
place on appelle vraiment régis ravanas
c'est le président d'air t elle alors je
crois qu'il à l'antenne allô allô c'est
cyril hanouna comment ça va résiste on
aurait depuis fait rien ça va être mon
registre en forme
bon on a dit on a dit que tu étais beau
enrichissant et compétents régis j'ai
quelqu'un
qui travaille pour toi qui as quelque
chose à te dire c'est isabelle morini
bosc
tu vois de qui il s'agit atta alors bien
sûr il résiste je te la passe bon alors
régis il m'emmerde inter est la première
radio de france merci à toi et moi que
c'est pas vrai nom mais pour être tout à
fait honnête on a été des coups lors du
wef voilà et tous les tournées tous les
deux numéros un ils n'ont pas voulu me
croire un désir alors régis je vais te
dire la vérité
franchement on est beaucoup plus rtl que
france inter dont 6,6 même si on a mal
on n'a rien contre eux france à terme on
est plus rtl france inter
mais c'est vrai que là parce que nous on
se bat sur ce tableau qui est à
l'antenne de france inter
6 millions neuf cent quarante quatre
îles auditeurs rtl 6 millions 563 me
voilà oui mais andré des arts il est en
réalité grill qui connaît très bien tu
connais bien les sujets de dior ouais
c'est raconter la part d'audience c'est
la multiplication du nombre d'auditeurs
par la curée des coudes et là vous êtes
à 13,4 toute égalité aurait presque à
tous les deux un bon et régis surtout
cattin d'amour et le pour lequel ce
sondage est ce qu'il ya des déchets sk
d'essence car t elle passe première à
d'outrance ou pas bella ont déroulé déjà
mais pour moi je trouve que c'est assez
france inter fait du très bon boulot
mais je trouve que rtl c'est un
excellent boulot voilà donc tout est
ainsi qu on soit avec des coups avec
avec france inter
bah nous nous tue c'est qu'on éprouve
rtn et on espère que lors du corps quand
rtl redeviendra première à de france je
peux te là on va faire une fête résister
te parle à tous la nécessité de passer
ton ami régis en tout cas je voulais
dire que tu es un super patron du cecos
t'aime très fort et tu te fais un super
boulot sur rtl et où je sais vous allez
faire une très grosse rentrée et on sera
toujours avec vous parce que c'est vrai
qu'à rtl et le groupe m6 c'est vraiment
voilà c'est la classe et franchement
vous jouez à chaque fois le feu voilà on
vous embrasse très fort un registre et
et on attend les sondages on avait on
sera pas l'an dernier mais et isabelle
voilà elle est en tout cas d'aller le
voir
elle vous défendre est vraiment quoi
qu'il arrive et ça ça c'est génial on
compte sur toi les ayvelles merci
registre et de rtl c'est un amour de
vraiment bon on peut l'applaudir
j'adore que oui je peux raconter une
anecdote de classe entre entre vous et
airtel parce que là on se chambre avec
un lit mais j'adore régis à corey est
vraiment non je voulais le dire parce
que le groupe m6 à chaque fois s'est
fâché du tout franchement on s'est dit
bon ben ya rien à dire c'est des avions
soit nicolas terme à nos registre là et
moi tu certes elle moi ils me font faire
du foot sur arte elle et j'avais fait le
malin je m'étais engagé sur rtl pour
faire le match dortmund paris saint
germain et j'avais dit à l'époque je
serai avec vous et pour vous dire la
classe d'hommes si certaines et de cire
et la menace il me dit tu fais tpm fait
démarche verte elle je peux le foot et
c'est parti en engueulades en fait dans
les coulisses parce qu'il voulait que je
fasse tpp moi je voulais aller faire les
fautes et en fait ils se sont appelés
tous les deux raté m6 ils ont trouvé un
arrangement se dit ok tu vas aller sur
sur rtl faire le foot cyril a dit ok
c'est des copains chez s'est déjà mis
chers tels va faire le foot et hurlant
raté pmp demain et les deux sont super
bien parlé j'ai eu des retours des
oliviers qui est en place avec christian
ollivier vous avez parlé agressive et
c'était très classe donc là on charrie
rtl on chambre mais est inquiète pas que
les rapports ils sont là et puis et puis
je voudrais dire un truc je veux redire
rtl c'est quand même grâce à eux moi que
j'ai pu faire tout ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui et je vous dis franchement
je veux vraiment qu'rtl soit produire à
d'autres france non plus c'est vrai ça
m'énerve quand je les vois deuxième
parce que je suis à fond
rtl mine de rien dans le coeur et voilà
j'espère qu'ils vont re voilà qui vont
redevenir première radio non mais non
mais ils sont là mes services et
égalitaire des branches il existe mais
l'augmentation est elle augmente de
france inter on demande vraiment à voir
le prochain sondage en tout cas je vous
dis voilà bravo un registre un masque
est à la bourre allez on joue maintenant
pour un dernier truc
une promo dans la rue de france inter
sur un caddie scooter avec megafon
regarder katrina
je me tue je vous jure que je me tue sa
valeur isabelle aller avoue je suis
sidéré par la bac et produira sur marne
était le slogan de rtl en 91 matches
c'est bien paru hier quatre choix
multiples non on n'a pas décroché de la
gaieté pas encore dépassé nagui ici
nagui l'essence inter allait le tuer
c'est dur ça change quand il y en a un
parent y en a deux parents allait jouer
aux dés en vente sans rtl l'information
en capital est pas le meilleur et écoute
écoute et isabelle morini-bosc bien sûr
sur rtl tous les jours à 9h15 et pour
l'instant isabelle rejoignez votre
caddie regarder france inter pour y
aller regarder les gens ont des attentes
dans la rue et c'est quoi bah vous allez
voir on va attendre les visages est un
sacré sais pas isa vous allez tous vous
êtes toujours pas le permis non mais non
merci je suis allée ressens mais je vous
rappelle que je suis tombé de vélo à la
règle je me suis fait une double
fracture du bazar mais là là là c'est un
fossile salaires
là je vais vous dire normalement ça va
avec le pistolet de berne à monter dans
les toilettes avec s'apprête à faire
beaucoup
le 28e pas aller là binôme à mes joies
mes doigts attention j'ai pris de la
vitesse voilà madrid ou
chic on y parle un peu plus de sonder
les attentes
[Rires]